Selena Gomez and The Weeknd aren't  afraid to show some PDA it's extremely  touching it's amazing  [Music]  twenty-seven-year-old grammy-winner  posted this intimate shot to instagram  saturday cozied up next to his 24 year  old girlfriend Selena planting a sweet  kiss on her man's cheek can't keep my  hands to myself this marks the first  time the star boy singer has posted  about his ladylove  while selena has shared quite a few  snaps of her man  while tagging along on his star boy  legend of the fall tour let me show you  how to pose the night before the weekend  posted the sweet snap the couple shared  a date night out in Los Angeles  [Music]  Oh